has any um uh buddy young guys or
whatever coming up come to you and said
billy i want you to produce my my music
don't they seek you out these guys to to
sort of help them maybe with a melody or
something like that in a studio yeah
from time to time a a younger artist
will ask if i'm interested in
co-writing with them or helping to
produce them
or coming up with something new uh men
and women writers
right um
uh
but i i i always beg off i say i i'm not
interested in doing that why not though
wouldn't that be fun for you i mean in a
sense you're a very good teacher i've
been around you you like mentoring
people you like explaining the business
to them i like helping people and i like
being able to guide people uh to avoid
making the same mistakes i made but i
don't want to get
hooked into
having to write again when
if it's not my own idea or if it's not
something i want to do
i'm not going to do it because it turns
out
it's not going to be very good if i
don't want to do it it's not going to be
real was there ever some moment in your
career where i don't know maybe george
harrison came to you or maybe uh
mccartney himself came to you or
somebody came to you and said let's do a
thing
where we're all accomplished guys we'll
all do our thing
and and make some kind of super group i
would think you'd be the guy they would
come to for something like that
um it's there's a few people um
john oates asked me to go up collaborate
with them but i couldn't figure out what
to do this is a long time ago this is
almost three years ago
right uh bert bacharach wanted me to
write a song with him
but he wanted me to write the words now
i'm the guy who writes the music first
i i don't write lyrics off to off the
cuff like bernie toplin does with elton
um and i i couldn't finish the project
the only person i've actually really
ever collaborated with was cindy lauper
i was stuck on a song
the name of the song was code of silence
so i'm already you know it's already
difficult code how do you write about
silence
right without it being sounds of silence
and uh so cindy says
she sees me in the studio because you're
really having a tough time with these
words aren't you and i said yes because
well just you play the song and just
throw out some words when you when
you're playing and i'll make some sense
out of it and we'll figure it out and
cindy i don't want to do this no no no
you go ahead you know she was like a you
know
the queen's chick pushing me to do
something come on you could do it but
come on let's figure this out so
we came up with these lyrics i gave her
credit she's i think the only other
co-writer i was ever able to work with
because she did all the work wow the
only other writer i gave credit to
on a collaboration was ludwig von
beethoven
because i stole a piece of his music
but i gave him credit i didn't pay him
but i gave him credit